welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and this is the
channel where we explain it so you don't
have to if you've been following me
since day one and then you'll know that
I'm a huge huge shining fan I've been
very excited for this movie since it was
first announced and roughly about this
time last year to celebrate I went back
and did an hour-long special on the
original movie having just watched the
new trailer for dr. sleep I can say that
there's a lot to unpack from it and
throughout this video I'll be going
through the teaser with a fine-tooth
comb to point out everything that you
missed this is full spoilers ahead so if
you don't want to know anything about
the film then I highly suggest that you
turn off now without the way I just want
to give a huge thank you for clicking
this video I hope you enjoy it and now
sit back relax and let's get into my
doctor's sleeper trailer breakdown okay
so from this opening shot it's very
similar to how Kubrick would actually
staged a scene there's a lot of symmetry
to it and I love the kind of arching
rooftop and yeah it's just a nice cell
now the B head doesn't look very real
and there's nothing kind of here that
would indicate that this is a shining
movie but you know the little hello here
that scrawled on the wall it's it's just
teasing that something's not quite right
now obviously the character Danny is
getting messages from the other side and
originally they seem quite playful that
kind of inviting him over to do
something about it
stupidly though he decides to contact
them back which is obviously inviting
spirits into his life and showing that
he's aware of this and yeah he's asking
for trouble here and there it is the
first tease that this is connected to
the shining red room is obviously
massively famous it's very much part of
the pop culture zeitgeist and it's
probably more known than this actual
movie The Shining is and it's just so
infamous and yet if you've seen that
film you know this is a very bad thing
to have appear on your wall okay so we
just saw a cut to abre stone there who's
played by Kiley Curran
she's jolted awake pretty much at the
same time that you McGregor's character
Danny is and you know this she's sort of
setting up what could be happening and
what is the main force of the film
your magic like me
the two of obviously contacted each
other psychically there's a point in the
trailer where Danny says to himself just
talk to the kid and this is where he's
reaching out to see if someone else has
psychic abilities anyone listen to me
place that place now these people here
are pretty much the bad guys of dr.
sleep they're known as the true not and
the basically sort of psychic vampire
people they sort of go throughout the
country and feed on pain mainly on
children who have psychic abilities and
that kind of empowers them and we see
Rebecca Ferguson who is the main villain
and she's known as Rose the Hat and she
sort of the main body of this story if
you read the book yeah she's not a nice
person to be around knowing that two or
three people I guess again we can see
them sort of attacking young children
with psychic abilities Danny in the
shining obviously was a young child with
massive psychic abilities and I think
he'll sort of be drawn into this to
defend abra who will obviously become a
target
when I was a kid I bumped into these
things yeah and there's the infamous
room 237 from the Overlook Hotel in case
you haven't seen the shining I don't
know why are you watching this video if
you haven't seen it but this is pretty
much the money shot of the trailer room
237 was where a lot of the ghost
activity in the Overlook Hotel happened
this is where the woman and the bathtub
was the carpets the same you know we
sort of did kind of wonder whether this
would be a sequel to the book or whether
it would be a sequel to Kubrick's film
now the fact that the carpets the same
the hotel looks the same it's definitely
definitely a tie-in to Kubrick's film
[Music]
and there again was the woman in the
bathtub if you've watched that scene
with Jack Nicholson that kind of sticks
in you nightmares a bit I don't know of
a magic eye
I was called at the shining and that is
before it chapter 2 apparently came out
that was the most blood ever used in the
scene before coming out the elevator
[Music]
so we did see they're sort of shots of
the Overlook Danny's obviously gonna
remember what happened and it's I think
it's really really a good idea that the
time back to that film
it's definitely something that I'm
interested in seeing I mean I pretty
much bought ready player one just for
the shining scene in that spoiler alert
but yeah you know this trailer is really
building up and there's a really tense
feeling here as you can sort of see the
true not hunting down abre of course the
twins from the shining they're amazing
[Music]
there is rose the Hat with glowing eyes
screaming I don't know what's happened
at this point but you know she's
probably just got to feared and it's
just amazing
[Music]
okay so what happened there was Danny
who was sitting in his room and he was
suddenly held towards the Overlook Hotel
now this is definitely the Overlook in
the present it's a lot dirtier it's very
creepy
it's very dilapidated and very rundown
and it's gonna be it's nice that in the
film they're gonna sort of have the old
version of it in Danny's memories but
also this modern version and I guarantee
it's gonna be a lot scarier than it was
in the original film
[Music]
yeah and it just looks incredible
obviously I kind of want to go back
there and show just where Danny sort of
went back to the Overlook now one thing
I didn't mention when I was breaking
this down is that this was sort of the
room with the mirrors in where a lot of
the the climax of the film actually
happened and so it's a very harrowing
place for Danny to be back in now what
makes this different from Kings book and
why it's probably leaning more towards
Kubrick it's because in the book the
Overlook was actually exploded basically
at the end of the story and so the fact
that it's still standing here shows that
ties in directly with Kubrick's film and
then you get the next shot where Danny
puts his head to a door that Jack
Nicholson chopped into as Jack Torrance
and said here's Johnny and I think it's
a really great way to end the trailer
and I'm massively excited for this
obviously I'd love to hear your thoughts
on this has it got you hooked on it or
are you kind of still a bit skeptical I
know a lot of people are still like I
don't think it'll caught the original
but I'm really really hyped for it
so make sure you leave your thoughts in
the comments below and if you enjoyed
this video then please give it a thumbs
up this is sort of a new style of
trailer breakdown I'm doing so if you
prefer this style or if you prefer the
old one make sure you let me know and I
can try and make the channel better for
everyone also I've just done a video
that covers all of the timelines and
parallel universes in the Avengers and
game film it took me a while and it's
definitely worth checking out so make
sure you give that a click it'll be
linked at the end this is the channel
for people who are mad into movies so if
that's the kind of thing you like hit
subscribe thanks again for taking the
time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time take
care
[Music]